people over complicate things that they
already know because the truth is too
difficult to stomach they don't want to
accept that they should just eat less
and move more and so they want to come
up with a hundred ways to be cute rather
than just confronting the fact they just
need to eat less and move more and like
they don't want to confront the fact
that they just need to work and
so then they're like I'm going to do all
these things to prepare myself to work
right and get myself in the right Zen
and like have an attitude of abundance
Aurora and like read my affirmations and
do my Daily Journal and all this stuff
when it's like dude the doing needs to
do it so it's just who's going to do it